thank you
[Music]
so have you guys heard about what the
heck and in the heck is going on with
Jamie Foxx is he is he in the hospital
yeah they think it's like from the
vaccine but there's a lot of speculation
about that yeah but yeah any sickness on
the vaccine and people do what happened
so he was filming a movie called back in
action with Cameron Diaz it was for
Netflix and they say he suffered a
medical complication and had a stroke oh
my God there's a lot of speculation
about like a lot of rumors
um Nick Cannon recently came out
apparently they've been friends for a
long time and he says he's not feeling
well they said it was a stroke I have no
idea what happened to him you trust Nick
Cannon as a source nah you don't trust
you can as a source do you work with
Nick no I don't trust him at all
because I know he wants to some high
profile people you know who I do trust
Snoop
Doggy I trust the hell out of Bun B Bun
B seems like a very good trust me it
Cannon we have friends that know Nick
Cannon yeah but they're not here right
now yeah he just I don't know I just he
has so many kids and the man with a lot
of kids you could trust him and also
what his statement was was about 12
months though it wasn't that insightful
I was like thanks Nick well it sounds
like he's talking around it because he
doesn't maybe like you ever been put on
the spot and you know something you're
not trying not to say is Nick Cannon an
anti-vaxxer and he goes I told you not
to get the [__] Pfizer one that's
what I read it yeah when I first heard
um I thought it was actually steroid
related really because I knew you
remember he was supposed to play Mike
Tyson yeah yes I was like how is he
gonna gain that much weight and I know a
lot of Jack then I know a lot of actors
they jump on the gear to like you know
they gotta play a role so it's that's
the end game and then so I'm like oh
[__] like you probably have to gain 50
pounds in like three like think about
the muscle do you think Christian Bale
did that uh for which one for like
because he went up and down like twice
oh yeah possibly possibly yeah or was
that all Nettie some of them doing 92
but it's it's hard it's easier it's
easier to and you're trying to make a
really believable role so you want to
look juice down you know especially
playing superheroes dude yeah you'd have
to be pretty big man yeah you're going
from like God's like 170 you got to be
like 220 all of a sudden
Christian Bale can do it Christian like
Jamie Foxx could do it too I feel like
Jay fox running for Jack he's pretty
good yeah but then he's already older so
if he's gonna play Young Mike Tyson
that's kind of yeah it is weird because
young Mike Tyson was he was big but he
was skinnier yeah I mean he's still big
but like yeah I I watched the interview
and when he was in eighth grade he was 5
10 like 205 pounds dude I'm like and
then and he grew up he didn't play
basketball he grew up on heroin in a
crack yeah so I'm like that was his
breakfast I'm like doing that and you're
like that much muscle like you're it
makes sense why you kill everybody
imagine if you just hit your protein
intake you know you'd be like 250.
I won a meeting with Mike Tyson before I
shook his hand his hand
is my chicken I was like oh definitely
don't want to get punched by that oh did
it feel like a glove yeah
did you say it's nice to meet you you
say it like that I'm a big fan close
your eyes and just try to Vision yeah
nothing said he couldn't eat sugar for
sure because talking about ice cream
what's a good food concept from Mike
Tyson's brand for him yeah he he eats
very healthy so he's on that like meal
prep time I can't eat sugar because if I
had it it'll wait a few years ago
you know there was Mike Tyson that would
never fight again yeah and then so he
did a podcast with them across the room
and then and he has his tables like this
big and then the table that we see now
it's like five feet wide almost and he
says it's because it's specifically for
Mike Tyson so once he started training
for the Roy Jones Jr fight that animal
came out of him again and then like him
entering into the room like Joe Rogan
felt scared so he's like I can't have a
podcast with you like this close like
you need to be wow like over there yeah
and it's always wondering like if he's
in the room like does it feel like you
know what yeah or he has that aura for
sure it just feels crazy yeah he was
like especially high level Fighters when
you talk to him you're like oh you can
kill me in like two seconds oh yeah
you're like get the [__] out of here
that's you in here [__] you dude dude
you crazy we're calling me higher level
you're calling me a high level fighter
is crazy you could kill us in two
seconds
yeah I was holding I was holding the
pads he's one of those guys all right
start hitting the pass right hit me and
then he's like he hit me I was like okay
that's that's like how hard is that he's
like 70. I was like okay I'm done thank
you
a lot of good work for Brandon too right
yeah killing it yeah he's killing it
he's doing a great job like how did you
help his like his whole like branding
and career and stuff um I teamed up with
Brandon at the end of 2021 uh I've known
him since he was 17 years old and we're
just catching up on lunch and he was
presenting a lot of he was asking me
questions about all this his brand deals
that he was doing and I'm like hey
well he asked me to help can you help me
out with it I was like okay I don't know
much about I don't really know much
about boxing but I know how to help
build brands and so me and uh our buddy
G teams up in the now we you know worked
with Brandon for the last year now
yes so you got him on to like a higher
tier of like sponsorships and stuff so
all the brand deals and collaborations
that we're working on for him
yeah so apparently
um the uh Jamie Foxx's uh daughter
Corinne came out and said we wanted to
share that my father experienced a
medical complication luckily due to
quick action and great care he's already
already on his way to recovery and
there's word that he wants to reach out
uh to his fans because he knows
everyone's worried about him and stuff
he's one of the good ones of Hollywood
we can't we can't afford to lose James
lots of people love him man he's
actually talented
actually
I love all of our resources must be
Jamie Foxx no word yet from um his slam
piece who is obviously Katie Holmes what
his slam pieces slamming around for a
couple really Katie home you're reduced
her to being a slam piece that's what I
read yeah
that's what they said apparently he's a
real slamaholic with her too he really
he really juices around yeah you look at
Jamie Foxx you're like that guy is a
number one Slammer for sure have you
ever seen one oh for sure any place is
really good pickleball is was it vaccine
related I read some of it nobody knows
there's no way to determine that right
it's what everyone guesses anytime
anything happens to anybody right now
who is the girl he always played was it
shanene
but then Jamie Foxx also played a girl
too Living Color that one yeah yeah I
forgot the name of that character yeah
Katie Holmes dude I wonder if he wears
that outfit to [__] Katie Holmes with he
calls her Katie holes oh
you really get the facts man yeah we
can't lose Jamie Foxx man nah dude he's
the best dude good great singer he's a
DJ too he does some pretty good stand up
he does everything yeah and uh and he
always wants to like meet people like he
meets a lot of like new people all the
time all the all my buddies that have
like worked with him in some sort of
capacity they're like he's so nice he's
a great guy you know that's what
everyone says he's not a dream client of
yours Jamie Foxx no he'll I don't know I
guess yeah sure what kind of business
would you open up for Jamie Foxx what a
weirdo if you guys if you guys were to
partner up on something with Jamie Foxx
I know something has to be something
within the entertainment reality
what if he wanted a food concept he's
like make me something I don't care what
it is what food goes with Jamie Foxx
yeah I know he seem like he'd have a
good type of Steakhouse
oh and then like a singing and and
Performing and once in a while he'll
come in and actually play piano and [__]
what if you did like a pug Sanctuary
with Jamie
what the heck there's something like you
know how they do like these plugs yeah
you can borrow
Fox Cafe
oh that'd be cool
God damn it they're just laughing all
the time have you heard of fox boy
cappuccino and a cannon with a fox yeah
all right I think or Nick Cannon should
we be
dude I think you found your next
business partners
great brainstorming room yeah Mike Tyson
he's like I got one for Mike Tyson
Kentucky Fried pigeons
because they love pigeon in China but
he'll like that because he loves pigeons
what about a door security system that's
so good that he can't even break into
your house to kill you if you wanted to
oh and then he's the one demonstrating
it yeah yeah a branded one yeah like
yeah like just like uh George Foreman oh
yeah come on open the [__] door
yeah he punches it and nothing happens
nothing happens yeah like dude
yeah that's why the best door money can
buy yeah and then we even do a
simulation where we have people inside
who are calling them all kinds of names
and [__] bringing up his court cases
Robin Gibbons is on the other side
it's pretty good he's using full power
and the door stays up
it only needs the you only need the
right integration and then you got the
next form and Grill
the George Foreman girl was a huge
[__] success it was a good product
crazy success so it was the first air
fryer yeah
fryer maybe yo the way that it just made
burgers though I was like what cooking
both sides at the same time fat drips
yeah I mean he seems like Smashburger
dude seems like such an open-minded guy
if you would have the ear gummies right
yeah yeah he did him in the Holyfield
did the air gummies together oh they did
it together yeah they did it together
that's cool like open-minded then right
is that why you met up with Mike Tyson
so you guys could collaborate on the ear
gummy too I should have I should have
hopped on that one what about a Jamie
Foxx nft that randomly stops working and
half of it doesn't work anymore
you got a lot of those